[Musique]
préparez la mdph de demain et améliorer
l'accompagnement des personnes en
situation de handicap un projet inscrit
sur une feuille de route est développée
au sein d'un programme national pour les
deux prochaines années
localement 5 objectifs territoriaux ont
été retenues pour mieux répondre aux
attentes et aux besoins de ce public
premier enjeu c'est vraiment des
garanties des droits à vie pour les
personnes qui sont en situation de
fragilité et dont la situation ne va pas
s'améliorer
le deuxième enjeu c'est comment on
traite les droits des usagers dans des
délais plus courts
donc c'est un ange est posée à même d ph
mais également au niveau des services du
département
c'est tout ce qui touche au tour du
paiement de la pch et le troisième enjeu
c'est vraiment comment on travaille sur
la division sociale et notamment
l'appuyons scolaire en garantissant
notamment une demande très forte des
familles comment avoir une aide à
l'éducation de ses enfants pour ceux qui
sont porteurs d'un handicap en lien avec
l'éducation nationale
faciliter l'accès au droit maîtriser la
qualité de service simplifié les
démarches et l'accès à l'information
ces actions s'engage à améliorer la vie
quotidienne des personnes en situation
de handicap
les cibles ont été donc capter et ça
c'est intéressant parce que lorsque les
cibles sont actés automatiquement ça
nous permet donc de serrer le travail et
de pouvoir faire avancer sur ces points
que nous sommes est essentielle
c'est vraiment chaque action appelle un
partenariat renforcé pour certains ce
sera du partenariat avec le département
pour d'autres avec l'éducation nationale
pour d'autres avec des associations pour
d'autres avec le secteur public de
l'emploi dont pôle emploi avait fait
partie pour trouver toutes les
articulations qui sont nécessaires
aujourd'hui pour le mieux vivre le
bien-être des personnes en situation de
handicap à la réunion cinquante six
mille personnes sont reconnues au sein
de la mdph
la diversité de ses bénéficiaires
implique une cohésion forte de la part
de tous les partenaires pour réussir la
mdph de demain
[Musique]